. Hallo Leipzig! Hallo Leipzig, herzlich willkommen! Was, dass Sie da sind. Lang ist es her.
Und Florian, die da Seitenstecken.
Oh, es kommt wieder das alte Gefühl.
Hey, schön, dass Sie da sind.
Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-Ufo.
Zu was?
Zum Podcast-Ufo.
Und ein Mann hat es sich nicht nehmen lassen, heute hier persönlich aufzutauchen. Es ist kein geringerer als Stefan Dietze! Und er hat es einrichten können zwischen Gamescom und anderen Großereignissen. Er ist wirklich hier in Leipzig bei euch, Leute, Florentin Will! Ach Mensch, ach ja, ach doch auch nett, ach ich auch, ja, ach das ist doch nett, Stefan. Und ihr seid natürlich auch heute hier, schön, dass ihr da seid, Leipzig ist mit dabei, herzlich willkommen. So, erstmal runterkommen. Was macht man bei Seitenstechen, was sind die neuesten, was sagen die neuesten Paper? Gibt es doch jemanden, der zu Seitenstechen forscht, während so Leute zu Corona und so forschen? Ich glaube schon, die sind extrem außer Atem, so ich habe die Lösung, ich habe die, ah, ah, ganz schlecht. Aber ich bin auch der Einzige, der weiß, was man machen muss, Arm hoch. Das einzige, was ich aus meinem Erste-Hilfe-Kurs noch zurückbehalten habe, ist der Ausdruck stabile Seitenlage. Nicht, was das genau ist, aber das mentale Konzept, so dass sollte ich jetzt jemandem begegnen, der irgendwie von einem Hydranten aufgespießt wurde oder sowas. Und dann komme ich da hin und habe mein Konzept. Weil Hydranten fliegen ja gerade durch die Gegend. Es ist ja, man kommt ja kaum noch aus dem Haus. Ich gehe deswegen nicht mehr raus. Was ist da los? Die haben ja auch immer nur gewartet. Meine ganze Kindheit habe ich schon mir gedacht, diese Hydranten, die stehen und auf irgendwas warten die. Und plötzlich sieht man selten. Und würde ich so jemanden treffen, würde ich mir denken, okay, stabile Seitenlage, wüsste aber nicht wie. Ich würde mich wahrscheinlich erst mal selber seitlich hinlegen, einfach mal gut für die Pressefotos. Und dann komme ich so vorbei. Stabil. Einfach um mal zu spüren, wie es ist. Ist es nicht die Regel, dass Ärzte alles, was sie an Patienten machen, auch an sich selber machen müssen? So, ich bin auch bei, wenn Leute sich liegen, dann mal jeden Gag machen, dann mal einen Moment sein und sagen, stabil. Das ist die stabile Seitenlage, Bro. Das stimmt, du kriegst eine Anzeige wegen unterlassener Hilfeleistung, aber der Richter sagt auch, guter Gag, muss man sagen. Das war einfach funny. Guter Gag, drei Jahre auf Bewährung, aber auch guter Gag. Das erinnert mich an die Geschichte, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die kennt, wurde, glaube ich, auch mal in einem ähnlichen Podcast ausgegraben, die Geschichte des Dave Matthews Band Poop Incidents. Oh ja.
Weil die irgendwann mal hat die Dave Matthews Band super coole, coole Jungs mit cooler Musik,
die sich auch, die jetzt nicht so den typischen Rockstar-Klischees entsprechen,
haben mal, irgendwie ist der Busfahrer mal losgefahren und hat irgendwie auf der Brooklyn Bridge oder sowas,
auf einer ähnlichen, ähnlichen, war was in Brooklyn, whatever in New York,
hat dann den Tourbus entleert, nämlich diesen Dump, einfach alles, was im Klo überbleibt. Und drunter ist gerade leider Gottes so ein Sightseeing-Boat langgefahren. Und das ist eine wahre Geschichte, der Wikipedia-Einsatz ist spitze, weil da sagt der Richter nämlich auch, ja, super tragische Geschichte und da sind auch Leute einfach zu Schaden gekommen, weil die Fäkalien in Münder, in Mouths, das ist das Witzigste bei dem B-Artikel, steht in Eyes, the Skin and Mouths. Ich meine, klar, Sightseeing ist natürlich die ganze Zeit in Komplett. Bei jedem anderen Boden war das merkwürdig, dass Leute so rumstehen, aber beim Sightseeing macht es Sinn. Und da der Richter nämlich auch gesagt, ja furchtbar, die Band muss die Strafe bekommen, aber es ist eine gute Band. Hat er gesagt. Ich dachte mir, yes. Eigentlich sollte es verboten sein, man sollte die Playlists von Richtern analysieren, bevor die so in Gerichtsprozess gehen. Nicht, dass der irgendwie das Album hundertmal gehört hat, steht Beyonce da Anklagebank und nur so, hey girl, einfach so, ich hau dich hier raus, kein Problem. Du bist schuldig, aber du bist eine gute Sängerin. Okay. Ich war noch nie bei einer Sightseeing-Tour, wirklich beeindruckt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich glaube, ich hatte noch nie meinen Mund mehr als 30 Grad offen bei einer Sightseeing. Wirklich nicht? Nee, ich war immun gegen solche Fäkalangriffe, einfach war ich selten beeindruckt. Naja, du wärst zu 70 Prozent immun. Das stimmt, aber ich glaube, das Schiff ist auch ein Problem, weil wenn jetzt irgendwie so die Fäkalattacke auf einem Schiff ist, du kannst nicht sagen, schnell, hinterher, so du bist einfach mit so einem Schiff so, ja, lasst uns langsam rechts ranfahren. Ihr Arschlöcher, wir kriegen euch vorgereicht. Genau, wir kriegen euch bei der nächsten Brücke.
Also wir müssen einmal weiter.
Es ist, du bist zu...
Eine gute Geschichte.
Und dann haben die da den Quatsch auf dem Boot abgeladen und sind dann weggefahren.
Und dann wurde danach so ein Investigativ-Team gebildet, so ein Investigativ-Team von der Polizei,
die dann herausfinden mussten, wer das genau jetzt verursacht hat.
Oh Gott, ey!
Und dann hat so ein Fitnessstudio auf der Überwachungskamera gesehen, wie der Bus, der beschuldigt wurde, der Busfahrer, dann tatsächlich einfach in Richtung dieser Brücke gefahren ist. Und niemand weiss, was ihn geritten hat, über dieser Brücke plötzlich diesen Mülleimer zu droppen. Alter, was eine Scheissidee. Aber auch das ist... Und die Air-Desaster auch. Ist auch der schlimmste Tag für so eine Bootscrew, oder? So normalerweise hast du dann einen guten Tag und dann siehst du nur diesen braunen Regen. Und dann denkst du, ah, fuck, einfach schrecklich. Ich dachte, das ist gerade noch der schlimmste Montag meines Lebens. Boot sprang erst nicht an, Kind wollte sich in die Kita, aber komm, vielleicht nimmt der Tag ja noch einen Turn. Oh, die Dave-Matthews-Band, die liebe ich. Oh nein, sie scheissen auch mit. Allerdings kann natürlich hier bei dieser Veranstaltung auch passieren. Diese Backstage-Toiletten sind portabel auf jeden Fall. Stefan und ich leben das grosse Tourleben. Wir haben sehr langsamen Tourbus, wir brauchen immer einen Monat, um von einer Stadt zur nächsten zu fahren. Aber in dem Monat sammelt sich eine Menge an auch. Weil es wie so eine Rikscha ist, flurbelte ein Pferd vorne.
Ja, genau. Stefan sagt immer, die zweite Hälfte der Tour tritt eher, aber irgendwie bis jetzt muss sich treten. Wir hatten noch nie die zweite Hälfte.
Ja, es hat noch nicht angefangen.
Aber ich fand es auch lustig, dann kam raus, dass es der Bus des Keyboarders war.
Und dann dachte ich mir, das willst du ja wirklich gar nicht, dass dann rauskommt, dass es deine Scheisse war, die dann auf so Leute abgeladen wurde.
Könntest du deine eigenen Fäkalien erkennen? Wer soll? Wir brauchen neun Freiwillige und dann bauen wir hier zehn Stühle auf. Nee, sorry, einfach mal, um das rabekommen, wer glaubt, dass er mehr als 60 Prozent erkennen würde. Nina aus Bottrop wettet. Komm mal, alle Ninas auf die Bühne, wie immer. Nee, nee, von Cruz, komm mal dazu, du bist ja Wettparte. Die wahrscheinlich Biosen Nina aus Bottrop wettet. Nina from Bottrop thinks that, dass sie ihre Fäkalien aus hundert Fäkalien wettet. find her own feces from up to 100. So, Nina, setz dich mal bitte dahin. Nina, sit down, please. Yes. So, Nina kriegt jetzt diese lustige Brille auf mit so zwei Kack-Emojis voll drauf. Ja, so, Nina, bist du denn selbstbewusst? Glaubst du, wie ist das denn? Tom Cruise ist der Meinung, du schaffst das. Ja, thank you Tom, ich habe das viel geübt mit meinem Vater jetzt die letzten Monate. Wie hat das genau ausgesehen? Ich meine, du bist ja keine professionelle Sanitärfrau, nehme ich an. Nein, also mein Vater hat... Das ist die Kinderwette übrigens, das macht sich besser. Nein, mein Vater hat bei sich auf der Arbeit gesammelt jeden Tag und dann musste ich ...
Was macht der Vater beruflich? Arbeitet er bei der Dave Matthews Band oder wo?
Nee.
Ach so.
Nee, mein Vater ist Richter.
Okay.
Hä, hast du was gezuckt?
Mein Vater ist Richter.
Haben Sie mich gerade geschlagen, Herr Gottschein?
Also ist die Brille noch nicht richtig?
Nee, Sie haben mich getroffen direkt.
Ne, ich, wissen Sie, was ich...
Was hält mal die Klappe?
So.
Okay.
Fäkalien, Tom Cruise muss jetzt zu sehr vielen
hinter die aufgebauten Fäkalien gehen.
Ich bin jetzt mal kurz Tom Cruise.
Oh, nice! Stefan Tietze, meine Damen und Herren, wir alle wandeln nur in seinem Schatten.
Wir dürfen zur selben Zeit leben wie Stefan Tietze. Können wir dafür bitte mal uns kurz freuen?
Was das für eine Ehre ist! was das für eine ehre ist aber ich bin gut wir wollen ja man mag gleich dazu ja so ein bisschen reiserische Gags zu machen für den Lacher und wir sagen uns immer an der Bühne, ne heute machen wir nicht die einfachsten Lacher. Dann mache ich die einfachsten Lacher und du stellst mich bloß.
Naja, es ist diese Kunstfertigkeit. Aber tatsächlich wollten nicht alle heute kommen.
Wer wollte nicht kommen?
Und zwar habe ich auf Twitter gesehen, dass Leute ihre Tickets verkauft haben.
Hatte ich auch gesehen.
Am besten fand ich den, der gesagt hat, ich verschenke mein Ticket live vor Ort.
Das heißt, es war jemand, der war hier, stand vor der Tür, hatte Zeit, zum richtigen Zeitpunkt und hat gesagt,
Vielen Dank. Das heißt, es war jemand, der war hier, stand vor der Tür zum richtigen Zeitpunkt und hat gesagt, nee, und hat sein Ticket verschenkt. Er hat gesagt, ich nehme den finanziellen Verlust in Kauf, verschenke ihn, aber ich hätte Zeit. Aber es ist dem, also ich habe das schon fast als ... Es ist wie uns zu sagen, wir haben euch immer gerne gehört, wo er jetzt nicht mehr...
Und da frage ich mich, wer hat dieses kostenlose Ticket bekommen von diesem mysteriösen Herrn, der hier einfach gesagt hat, also ich habe Zeit, der wartet auch, die gesamte Show...
Steht draußen.
Danach, euch wieder das Ticket abzunehmen, keine Ahnung.
Hat jemand das kostenlose Ticket bekommen, hier von einem mysteriösen Menschen da vorne? Hier, da ist tatsächlich da vorne? Wirklich? Ruf mal rein, was da die Geschichte ist. Wie heisst du denn? Du kannst den Arm jetzt runternehmen. Sorry. Ja, mein Mitwohner hat mich heute Morgen noch zugegeben. Er hat noch viele Menschen gesagt, die haben nun gelegt. Mit dem Bewohner hat sich da auch hingewiesen. Moment, aber dein Mitwohner ist dann extra noch mit dir hierher gegangen, um dir hier das Ticket zu überreichen.
Der ist auch dabei, oder? Er geht den Arm hoch.
Das ist eine komplett andere Geschichte bei euch beiden. Ich habe mir einen ganz anderen Film in der Videothek ausgeliehen.
Aber gut, dass jemand sagt, ich muss kurz gerade stellen, als hätte sie einen Anwalt mitgebracht.
Einspruch, okay, stark gegeben. Okay, es hat nichts mit der Story zu tun, also die Flurin die gerade erzählt hat, worauf die Frage basiert. Dein Ex ist in Kanada? Jetzt wird es mir seriös. Das habe ich schon häufiger gehört. Das ist eins vor Argentinien. Ja, das kenne ich auch. Ich habe eine Freundin, aber die lebt in Kanada. Und die ist halt kein Mensch. Das läuft richtig gut. Die sind ehrlich in Kanada. Ich habe das nicht genau verstanden. Wer ist in Kanada und was hat das hier mit zu tun? Ach so, weil der eigentlich hierher wollte. Wow, kann man nicht mal aus Kanada hierher kommen, um Stefan Tietze zu sehen oder was? Meine Güte. Ich habe das tatsächlich als Kind meine Zeit lang, weil als Kind kennt man sich ja nicht aus, also nicht so wie heute, mit sowieso Beziehungssachen mit Mädchen und so. Jetzt gerade weißt du ja, hast du alle Bücher gelesen? Klar, ich habe das Lexikon geschrieben quasi. Und dann war ich im Urlaub in Italien und dann war da im gleichen Urlaubsressort, waren halt auch andere Kinder, mit denen hat man dann so gespielt. Im Ressort? Im Ressort, ja. Das ist eingezäunt, Elektrozaun, so ganz schön, keine Erwachsenen. Und nur ein Kind hat überlebt tatsächlich, das war die Idee, ein Kind nach Hause. Und da finden sich natürlich Verbindungen. Der Stärkste oder was? Ja, das Schlauste. Ich bin nämlich im Pool untergetaucht. So ist Good Game mässig. Und da habe ich auch ein Mädchen kennengelernt, Helena hieß sie. Gott hab sie selig. Und ja, tatsächlich. Ich meine, nach deiner Geschichte hat sie es ja nicht mit rausgeschafft. Nicht da draußen. Und dann habe ich halt mit der halt mal irgendwie so Pokémon gespielt und dann wusste ich nicht, sind wir jetzt zusammen oder nicht, was ist jetzt der Status und dann bin ich nach Hause gefahren, habe sie nie wieder gesehen. Hast du gewonnen? Ich habe gewonnen, ja. Es war, beide Decks waren von mir, ja, ja, ja, ja, okay, danke, danke, danke, danke, danke, danke, weil darum geht's uns, darum geht's uns vom Das Podcast, vom Podcast-Projekt, wir wollen wissen, wer Pokémon gewonnen hat, lieber als wäre diese Beziehung, oder? Und nein, es war so, beide Decks waren von mir, Pokémon-Karten spielen, ich hatte zwei Decks, da wird eine Schwäche gegeben, sie hat das Feuerdeck bekommen, ich hatte das Wasserdeck, also ich war so der Real-Life ein bisschen, der so das falsche Tier. Okay, ein paar. Jetzt hast du mich verloren. Real Life Gary? Ja, der immer das Pokémon nimmt, das Gutes gegen deines, was du am Anfang nimmst. Ich war bei SpongeBob, ich war in einem ganz falschen Franchise. Real Life Gary, das war doch die Schnecke, was hat denn die Schnecke? Na gut, in einer Folge hat sie vielleicht mal die obere Hand gehabt. Ich könnte mich nie in dich verlieben, Stefan, wirklich, nie. So wenig Ahnung über Pumpe. That's what she said. Hey Mann, es tut mir immer noch leid. Nee, du wolltest das Thema nicht ansprechen. Okay, so. Naja, auf jeden Fall bin ich dann, habe sie nie wieder gesehen, bin zurück nach Deutschland gefahren, dachte aber, ich wäre jetzt in einer Beziehung, so mit zehn oder so. Dachte ich halt so, ja, ich bin jetzt vergeben und habe dann halt auch allen erzählt, so, ja, nee, ihr habt Helena kennengelernt in Italien und so, Fernbeziehung, ak, ich kenne nur ihren Namen, sonst nicht. Aber der Begriff Fernbeziehung war der mit zehn Jahren schon ein Begriff. Ja, auf jeden Fall, klar. Sexting auch, hatte kein Handy.
Nee, nee, aber mit Briefen hat man dann gesextet.
Also man sass gegenüber voneinander und hat dann aufgeschrieben, liebe Helena.
So ein Sextelegramm, einfach so.
Willst du mit mir gehen? Ja, nein, nur Sexting.
Ja, was hast du an? Stopp.
Das ist ein sehr langer Tisch. Das ist ein sehr riesen Tisch zwischen uns. Okay, wird spannend. Oh, okay, Sexting, ja. Okay. Willst du mit mir im A? Wir sind jetzt achtzehn in diesem Sketch. Sehr gut, er hat dazugelernt.
Es gab in der Zwischenzeit einen Zeitsprung von sieben Jahren in dem Sketch.
Er hat aus der Mainz-Show dazugelernt.
Mein Anwalt gibt das Go.
Ja, okay.
Willst du mit mir A 69?
Ach Gott.
B C.
Wir können uns auch an diesen Tisch stellen, der ist ein bisschen...
Oh.
Der ist nicht so ganz so breit.
Ich schreibe mal meinen ersten Move.
Kannst du euch vorlesen? Bitte. Länger, länger klatschen. Länger klatschen, da habe ich mehr Zeit, nachzudenken. Na musst so ein normales Gespräch wie so bei einem Porno, du startest ja auch erst mit Ding Dong, Hallo. Was hast du gerade an? Okay, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, im Alter von elf bis einundzwanzig dachte, ich wäre in einer Beziehung mit Helena und vielleicht ist die Publikum, Helena? Damals, Italien, 1999 niemand, nein, zack, eines Tages sehe ich viele Siefen. Ich sehe eine Serie. Ich habe gewartet, 20 Jahre habe ich gewartet. Bist du so ein Mafiaboss geworden? Sie ist Mafiaboss geworden, ja. Meine Leute haben dich überall gesucht, aber nirgendwo habe ich dich gefunden. Wir haben ihn. Don, Don, Donner? Donner, Donner Helena.
Donner Helena, wir haben ihn gefunden.
Sollen wir ihn reinbringen?
Florin Fiorentino.
Wir haben Florin Fiorentino.
Mein, mio Fiorentino.
Okay.
Ist dich 20 Jahre nicht gemeldet, Fiorentino.
Sorry, sorry, keine. Häuser können nicht fremden. Zwanzig Jahre habe ich auf dich gewartet.
Ja.
Wie wär's mit einer Revanche-Pokémon?
Diesmal such ich die Decks aus.
Helena, ich dachte, wir wären zusammen gewesen.
Es war rein nur, damit wir möglichst viele Leute, was, ich habe mir damals gedacht, wie kriege ich möglichst viele Leute in den Raum, um Helena wiederzufinden. Wie romantisch das wäre, wenn ich sie jetzt irgendwann wiederfinden würde. Und dann wäre es super tragisch, wenn sie irgendwie umfällt, du kannst stabiler Seitenlage nicht, siehst du. Oh nein, weil ich wusste es, dass ich damals hätte aufpassen sollen. Stell dir das vor, ihr trefft euch wieder nach all den Jahren, irgendwo, Sizilien. Ich stelle ihr aus Versehen ein Bein, sorry. Du stellst ihr ein Bein, weil du so aufgeregt bist. Sie freut sich aber mega. Sie gibt mega süss damit um, dass du so ein bisschen awkward bist.
Er hat eine mega Zeit. Dann fällt sie um, unglücklich mit dem Kopf auf so einem Stein.
Gibt es ja häufig in Sizilien.
Ja, oder überall sonst. Heisser Stein, ja.
Ja genau, sie fällt hin und alle rufen, oh nein, sie kann nur überleben, wenn du jetzt sie in die stabile Seitenlage legst.
Ich laufe vorbei. Stabil.
Okay.
Du weisst nicht mehr, wie es geht. Ja, sie stimmt. Das wäre tragisch. Ohne Scheiss, weil es müssen doch Rettungssanitäter O.E. hier gerade anwesend sein, oder? Kann uns jemand jetzt live auf der Bühne die stabile Seitenlage... Oh Gott, ich werde so aufgeregt sein, ich werde nicht aufpassen. Ich werde immer nur an Helena denken, ich bin so unter Druck, wenn ich das nicht schaffe, stirbt Helena. Kann hier irgendwer die stabile Seitenlage oder werden wir verloren im Fall eines Crashes, eines Flugzeugabsturzs, der hier reinbrät. Denkt dran, ihr habt einen hypokrondischen Eid geschworen. Damit geht man nicht leichtfertig um. Moment, das heißt, Sie dürfen das Wissen nicht weitergeben? Ja, genau. Oder wie viele Spüre gelingt man so ab in dem Medizinstudium? Weil wenn das ab dem Studium schon gilt, dann dürfen Sie das Wissen nicht weitergeben. Es ist so geil, dass das die einzigen sind, die so einen coolen Schwur schwören dürfen. Es gibt keinen Podcaster-Schwur, irgendwie so ein Eid oder irgendwie sowas cooles. Nee, weil wir leben davon, dass wir Dinge öffentlich sagen. Nehmen sowas wie das Gegenteil. Bei uns im Bekanntenkreis sagen alle, wenn dann schon, sagst du bitte nicht im Podcast. Weil alle schon davon ausgehen, dass man das sagt. Ja, das ist der hypokronische Eid, der Podcaster-Eid. Du darfst nichts Cooles im privaten Gespräch erzählen, sonst kann man es nicht mehr im Podcast erzählen. Deswegen ist es immer sehr unangenehm, Stefan und ich, Backstage, wir schweigen uns nur an. Und hoffen, dass wir endlich rauskommen. Aber in der Zwischenzeit kann ich dir erklären, weil das Heimlich-Manöver fand ich immer sehr wichtig für mich, weil ich ein grosses, oder heisst es heimlich Griff im Deutschen wahrscheinlich, heisst, dass der Move, wenn du machst, wenn sich jemand versuckt verschluckt aber der darf nicht damit rechnen du musst dich so anschleichen genau the secret the secret maneuver genau und den habe ich mal gelernt ich weiß noch nicht mehr ob ich es noch hinkriege weil meine grosse angst ist dass ich bei kfc sitze sehe neben mir der ältere herr hat sich auch ein neunzehner bucket geholt ganze Zeit Chicken Wings. Es ist eigentlich nur ein Wettrennen, wer erstickt als erstes. Jetzt die Frage, wer von uns zuerst, bitte ich, weil dann muss ich das Heimmanöver nicht machen. Ich bin der Erste an ihm dran, wenn er jetzt, das kriegt er nicht hin. So, und dann habe ich es mal gelernt. Achtung, komm mal näher, ich passe gar nicht, warum du jetzt weggehst. Hilfe, ein Helm! Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Dankeschön, ich bin geheilt.
So, Sicherheit.
Nein, Schritt eins, das war der Schritt eins.
Ihr müsst jetzt für alle 22 Schritte applaudieren.
Schritt eins ist Ruhe, für Ruhe sorgen, beruhigen. Nun machen Sie sich mal keine Sorgen. So, dann muss ich von hinten kommen. Jetzt legt man die Hand so zwei Finger breit. Nee, ich muss den Bauchnabel suchen. Ist gleich vorbei, ist gleich vorbei. Soll ich dir helfen? Beruhigen Sie sich erst mal. Es ist auch mein erstes Mal, Stefan. Hilf mir kurz, deinen Bauchnabel zu finden. Ja. Da. Oh ja. So. Zwei Fingerbreit. Nicht aufhören, nicht aufhören. Ja, ja. Weil eigentlich könntest du nicht sprechen, weil du ja 19 Chicken Wings in der Rache hast. Oh, das hört mich ein bisschen an, hätte ich gesagt. Ja, mich auch. Zwei Finger breit über dem Bauchnabel, da denk ich mir schon... Wessen Finger, meine oder seinen? Meine. Deine Finger? Ja, über dem Bauchnabel, da wird gleich reingeballert. So, jetzt mache ich die Hand dahin und jetzt muss ich kurz das Mikro beiseite, wobei ich halte es kurz fest.
Damit wir hören. Und jetzt nimmst du die andere Hand und haust da drauf. Meine Hand? Warum? Der, der gerade schockiert, was aus dem Publikum gerufen hat, weißt du es besser? Okay, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, ruhig jetzt mal.
Nee, Sie können das auch gerne machen. Ich gucke hey, hey, hey, hey, ruhig jetzt mal.
Nee, Sie können das auch gerne machen. Ich gucke mich im KFC rum. Ich will das hier nicht machen.
Okay, entspann dich, Sie machen das super, okay? Man merkt Ihnen nicht an, dass Sie das nicht viel Erfahrung haben, okay? Das ist richtig gut.
Nee, warte, ich weiss jetzt auch, warum du was geschrieben hast, pass auf.
Ich muss selber mit der Art von Faust. Man macht die Faust, das wechsle ich immer, das ist eine 50-50-Jahr.
Ich nehme die Faust und hau dann so drauf. Es kommt raus. Also, wieder was gelernt. Heimlich Manöver von Stefan Tietze. Wie viele Menschen leben alleine dadurch? Ich meine, klar, für die Hörer jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig interessant, die es einfach schnell nochmal skippen. Oh, Folge 323, da war doch heimlich mal über schnell und dann keine Ahnung. Wo sollen die Finger hin? Wo sollen meine Finger hin? Zwei Finger breit über dem Bauchnabel, eine Faust bilden, andere Hand kommt von der anderen Seite und schlägt, und da niemand mir widerspricht, nehme ich an, das ist richtig, auf den Magen, so oft, bis der Chicken Wing ausploppt. Okay. Und kann man den dann noch essen, oder ist es ...
Und hier kommt es auf die drei Sekundenregel an.
Kommt drauf an, wie schnell du bist.
Ja, das ist immer so meine Frage, wie lange dauert es dann, bis man normal weitermacht?
Angenommen, du hast jetzt so 25 ...
Setzt man sich dann wieder hin an seinen ... Ja, du hast jetzt 25 Wings, beim zweiten erstickst du wirst gerettet ah danke dir du hast ja immer noch hunger also du hast ja also wie geht es sogar noch mehr als vorher ja im grunde schon was sind da die regeln das ist glaube ich dein blick backstage als sie gerade wir haben salzschlange gegessen die ist die hälfte der salzschlangegefallen auf dem Boden und du hast mich ja angeguckt, du hast mich so angeguckt, so. So in der Mischung aus, hat er es gesehen, wie lang kann es noch da liegen, bis ich es auf gar keinen Fall mehr essen darf und genauso wäre es ja mit den Chicken Wings auch. Für mich gibt es eine einfache Regel, wenn mir was aus dem Mund fällt und ich schaue nach unten und ich kann es in der Fettlandschaft nicht auf Anhieb finden, ist es weg.
Es ist nicht mehr mein Problem. Die Schwerkraft hat gesprochen, soll die sich drum kümmern? Ich habe damit nichts mit zu tun.
Die Schwerkraft hat gesprochen.
Ich esse alles, was auf dem Boden fällt. Immer. Ich habe noch nie was nicht gegessen, was auf dem Boden fällt. Noch nie.
Ich glaube, wir haben noch nicht die perfekte Freundschaft gewonnen, weil ich muss mich noch vor dir zusammenreissen. Wenn mir vor dir Essen runterfällt, werfe ich es noch weg, nur weil du im Raum bist. Du hast mich anguckt wie so ein Hund, der so kurz davor ist, die Tischdecke runter zu reissen oder sowas. Ein Hund, der vor seinem eigenen Erbrochenen sitzt und sich denkt, ich würde. Wenn du dich da wärst. Ich würde. Also, von mir aus spricht nichts dagegen. Aber ich bin bereit, deinen moralischen Kompass zu respektieren. Aber ist hier irgendwer im Raum, der was dagegen haben könnte? So soll er jetzt sprechen oder für immer schweigen. Nein, Bello. Okay, dann nicht. Bello. Krieg heisst es auf Latein. De bello gallico. Hast du irgendwie, hast du, wie geht's dir? Ich habe das Gefühl, du willst irgendwas kompensieren mit deinen medizinischen, lateinischen Facts. Ich schuf mir so ein paar Dokus an. Und mir fiel ein aus meiner Schulzeit, dass wir De bello gallico gelesen haben, alle den Gag machen wollten, dass es Der gallische Hund heisst.
Ja. Und das war der grösste Lacher im Latein, das war der glücklichste im Moment.
Es sei denn, du nennst deinen Hund Bello Gallico. Das gibt es wahrscheinlich auch schon, die Lateinlehrer, deren Hund Bello Gallico heisst oder sowas.
Ich hasse Lateinlehrer so sehr.
Zum Glück, also sorry, man soll nicht über Tote lästern, aber Latein fick dich. Einfach mal hau ab, komm nie wieder zurück. Ich glaube, da muss ich keine Sorgen machen. Ich glaube, dass irgendwann, ah, Prophezeiung, wir können heute prophezeien. Meine Prophezeiung, es ist ja aktuell, es gibt ja Jugendtrends und so, die wir nicht kennen, ich glaube, einer der nächsten Jugendtrends wird sein, Latein kommt zurück. Dann gibt es nämlich lauter so Latinozismen oder so, dass die Leute da nicht so, weil die versuchen, jetzt so gerade die coolen Leute, die streamen ganz viele Anglizismen, aber wenn die uncool werden, müssen sich die Jugend wieder irgendwie davon differenzieren und die fangen an mit Latinuzismen. Wobei, du hast ja recht, also der Rindwertstrend ist ja erkennbar bei den heutigen Jugendwörtern, wo zum Beispiel das Wort bodenlos dabei war, Ja ich lachen musste, weil es wurde nicht mehr entfremdet oder so was, sind entfremdet, es heisst immer noch das Gleiche, ohne Boden. Und das Wort Macher fand ich auch sehr lustig. Moment mal, bodenlos ist auch eines dieser Wörter, die ich bis jetzt nur in Verbindung mit Frechheit kenne.
Also ich glaube, ich habe noch nie was anderes ausser einer Frechheit als bodenlos bezeichnet.
Also wenn jemand sagt, ich bin ein bodenloses Buffet hier. Nie sagen, das Konzert gestern, es war bodenlos. Was, bodenlos was? Bodenlos toll. Diese verdammte Jugend. Es geht so weit! Die Beyonce ist ein richtiger Macherin.
Sie ist eine bodenlose Künstlerin.
Aber ist es bodenlos denn gut oder schlecht?
Das weiß ich nicht genau. Ist jemand aus der Gen Z da?
Ich glaube, wir haben hier niemanden unter 30, oder?
Außer es wird jemand geboren jetzt gerade.
Könnte ja sein. Ich meine, ab einem gewissen Punkt.
Ich meine, statistisch wird alles irgendwann wahrscheinlich, wenn die Menge grossen Nututz ist. Ja, ja, statistisch gesehen kommen wenig Schwangere hierher jetzt. Hm, weiß ich nicht. Wobei uns hat eine ganz liebe Hörerin geschrieben, das Konzert, wollte ich gerade sagen. Sorry, sorry. Du willst deinen Kontrabass noch ausholen, oder Stefan, du willst es im Backstage immer, komm, lass mich ein Solo spielen. Dass dieser lächerliche Gig schon so lange verschoben wurde, dass ein Kind irgendwie ein halbes Jahr in Planung war. Okay. Man muss ja jetzt zusammen, nein, wahrscheinlich war man länger zusammen, halbes Jahr in Planung, dann geschwängert, dann zehn Monate vergangen, es wurde zur Welt gebracht, lebt jetzt schon fünf Monate auf diesem Planeten und hat ein Ticket bekommen doch und könnte jetzt wieder easy hierher, hat aber in der Zwischenzeit gemischtes Hacker-Index und ist weggegangen. Nein, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob es heute Abend hier ist, aber ich fand es sehr lustig, um zu veranschaulichen, wie lange wir diesen Ausschuss bereits verschoben haben. Moment mal, also ich will jetzt nicht basic anatomisches Wissen hier irgendwie hinterfragen, aber wie sieht die Planung für ein Kind aus? Versuchen, es versuchen, es planen, checken, finanziell verchecken, verchecken. On fire heute der Stefan. Vögel, okay, ja, ich hab's verstanden. Ich hab's verstanden. Ich dachte wirklich, man müsste das irgendwie so wirklich planen, so wo sollen die Beine hin oder wo sollen wir Kopf oben oder unten. Also ich dachte beim Kopf irgendwie an, aber korrigier mich Schatz, wenn ich falsch liege, aber Haferbrot, aber gut. Ja, also ich dachte immer, zwei Arme sind zu wenig. Okay. In meinem Leben wäre es nicht cool, wenn es so wie so vier Arme hätte. Okay, Schatz. Symmetrie, Symmetrie ist mir wichtig, da sind wir auf einer Seite. Ich soll ja nicht mehr sofort dagegen reden, wir haben ja gesagt, Brainstorming ist wichtig und so. Aber jetzt hat der kleine Louis Leandro Francesco ja schon seinen wunderschönen Kringelschwanz. Genau, ja, der kommt halt auch in die Quere der Flügel. Ist das schwierig? Ja, genau, bei den Flügeln wollte ich dich doch mal fragen, ob wir die brauchen. Dann lass uns ein Armpaar streichen und dafür ein Flügelpaar. Du hast oft gesagt, die Schwerkraft hat gesprochen. Ja, nicht mehr lange, nicht mehr lange, dann sprechen wir zurück. Deswegen sehe ich den Punkt für den Flügeln, ja. Okay, dann haben wir doch einen Kompromiss. Wir haben ein wunderschönes kleines fliegendes Kind. Okay, dann, was müssen wir jetzt machen? Mehr nach links, heißt es. Ach so, okay. Wir müssen beim Sex mehr nach links gehen, dann kriegen wir das so hin. Und dann, der war geschichtlich. Links, links, oben, unten, Start, select, links.
Das ist der Code für dieses Kind. Oben, rechts, unten, links, oben, rechts, unten, links, R1, R2, R1, R2.
Ich glaube, man kann da so viel Bullshit mitmachen, mit so Mythen, wie man irgendwas bewirken kann oder so.
Ein GTA-Cheat war R1, R1, L1, R1, oben, unten, oben, unten, oben, unten, oben, unten, oder? So ähnlich. Nicht? Der Panzer. Die gesamte erotische Stimmung, die wir aufgebaut haben. Ja, ich wollte die wieder runterziehen. Die letzte halbe Stunde ist weg. Also das ist wirklich dein Sweet Talk einfach so. Übrigens, der GTA-Sheet war R1. Das ist dein Sexting einfach so, lass mich bei dir R1 und dann R2 drücken. Was? Naja, dann zieht er sich aus. Ah, okay. Dann kriegt er jetzt eine Badehose und dann haut er Badehose. Nee, aber ich habe jetzt neulich gedacht, wir haben die Jugend verloren, nicht nur bei diesem Jugendwörter-Ding, sondern auch bei einer neuen App, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die schon mal gehört habt, mir war es neu, wurde mir dann erklärt, Be Real. Hast du von der App Be Real gehört? Nein. Es ist ein bisschen wie Instagram, nur dass du im Laufe des Tages, ich glaube fünfmal oder dreimal, eine Push-Mitteilung bekommst und dann hast du zwei Minuten Zeit, ein Foto von dir zu machen oder von deinem Tag.
Du hast zwei Minuten Zeit und dann kannst du es hochladen und die Idee ist halt, dass du authentische Fotos von dir hochladen kannst.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Finde ich auch.
Du weisst nicht, wann diese fünf Zeitpunkte am Tag sind?
Nein, plötzlich am Tag, du bist irgendwie mitten in einem Meeting mit deinem Boss.
So, unangenehmes Gehaltsgespräch. Klassischer Alltag eines Jugendlichen, ja. Du bist beim Rummikub spielen, als plötzlich die Push-Nachricht kommt. Okay, also wir sind mit Helena am Pokémon spielen und plötzlich kriegst du eine Push-Nachricht und ich habe gesagt, du hast zwei Minuten, das ist ein Countdown. Mega stressige App, stell ich mir das vor. Und dann musst du in der Zeit in zwei Minuten ein Foto machen. Krass. Und die Idee ist, dass du dann sozusagen dich echt und authentisch präsentierst. Okay, und da bis du allen alle Tabs zugemacht hast und so zwei Minuten reichen. Richtig, genau. Auf jeden Fall. Okay. Hast du es schon mal probiert? Nein, noch nicht, aber... Aber du folgst dann anderen Leuten, die das dann auch posten. Die es auch machen, genau. Wie Instagram in der Hinsicht. Ich finde es ziemlich clever. Das ist gut. Warum hatten wir die Idee nicht? Ja, wir hatten ähnlich gute Ideen, aber jetzt, pass auf, meine Weiterentwicklung ... Wir hatten den zufälliger Emoji-Button, das ist eine ganz andere Idee. Auch gut, immer noch gut, aber nicht die. Vor allem der Pokerchip-Emoji, den gibt es immer noch nicht. Und seitdem wir das damals mit den neuen Emojis gemacht haben, sind die fünf Jahre vergangen. Ja. Und irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, tausend neue Emojis sind entstanden, und der Pokerchip ist immer noch nicht einer der Nähe ist liegen. Mittlerweile glaube ich, das ist ein direkter Angriff auf uns. Auf uns. Dass Sie diesen Pokerchip einfach nicht wollen. Ich meine, dein durch die Tür rausgehen war albern, damals schon albern. Ich fand's gut. Aber vielleicht hat's was mit Glücksspiel zu tun, dass man das nicht machen darf oder so. Ah, finde ich gut. Keine Ahnung, weißt du, an anderen Gründen kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Pokerchip ist perfekt. Aber jetzt pass auf, es wäre meine Idee nämlich, dass man das zu einer Dating-App macht, weil Dating-App, niemand versteht sich so sehr und will so sehr hot und cool sein wie auch Dating-Apps. Deswegen gibt's eine Be-Real-Tinder-Version, wo du, und jetzt kommst, pro Woche kriegst du fünf Push-Mitteilungen an random Terminen und hast dann, wir machen daraus 30 Sekunden nur, Zeit hast, ein Foto von dir zu machen. Schaffe ich auch noch. 30 Sekunden, seit es ein Foto von dir zu machen und jede Woche hast du neu die Chance, jede Woche kriegst du fünf Möglichkeiten, ein Foto von dir zu machen.
Finde ich eine gute Idee.
Ja, oder nicht? Finde ich eine richtig gute Idee. Heißt, das Podcast... Aber du meinst dann erst, nachdem man sich matcht, oder... Ach, so kommt der Gag an. Das ist ja immer gut zu wissen, wenn man Gags macht, die wir tausendmal wiederholen, und dann macht man den einmal live, niemand lacht, und jetzt werden wir den auch nicht mehr machen. Die Leute kennen ihn, ja.
Aber das heisst, du siehst dann nicht ein cooles Profil von ihr am Strand, sondern du siehst fünf random Bilder und sagst, okay, cool. Sie auf dem Klo, musst du schnell ein Bild machen, wo geil wäre, auch wenn du es gar nicht auslöst und dann einfach es einfach. Aber das wäre gut, ja. Das wäre auch nicht schlecht. Einfach so direkt am Gesicht einfach. Ganz viel gelangweilt gucken. Ja, aber wenn du da jemanden swipes, ist die Chance sehr gut, dass du wahrscheinlich seines Voneinander gemacht hast. Finde ich eine richtig gute Idee. Vielleicht finde ich Helena dadurch, vielleicht finde ich sie, wie sie irgendwie in so Pokémon-Karten abfotografiert, wie sie trainiert. Jetzt seit 20 Jahren trainiert sie einfach jeden Tag, bis sie mich eines Tages schlägt. Aber viel eine gute Idee. Aber stressig halt. Aber steht uns irgendwas im Weg, das als App rauszubringen? Ja, Skills. Oh. Programmier-Skills. Diese verdammten Fähigkeiten. Immer dieses Talent, was wir schon alles hätten machen können, wenn uns das Talent dafür nicht fehlen würde. Kann hier jemand programmieren? Oh, sehr viele Finger hoch. Oh, wirklich? Ja, dann ist es nichts wert. Sorry, dann sucht euch einen neuen Job. Sorry, wenn sich die Hälfte meldet bei eurer Kernkompetenz, dann war es das nichts. Nee, sorry, das ist zu viel. Aber du, aus der vierten Reihe, du hast ja gerade auch aufgezeigt, wie schwer war das zu programmieren, wäre nicht so schwer. Sag mal auf der Skala von eins bis zehn, wie schwer das wäre. Ne, von eins bis null. Alle, aber du musst davon ausgehen. Florentin, Will! Vielen, vielen Dank, Dankeschön. Was hat er gesagt, das ist schwer?
Ich will es mir scheiße.
Mit dir will ich einen Comedy-Podcast haben.
Dankeschön.
Und ich weiss, wir nennen ihn das Podcast-Upo.
Ein neuer Podcast.
Wow, ja, mega Name.
Wir fangen einen zweiten Podcast an, der einfach genau so heisst.
Einfach nochmal. Ja, nein. Und, okay, ist mir das noch nicht geantwortet? Bitte? Sieben. Das sind sechs zu viel für uns. Das funktioniert so nicht. Müssen wir zurück ans Whiteboard. Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich denke immer so, wenn du selber so eine Dating-App programmierst, das ist zu viel Macht. Das ist zu viel Macht. Du würdest doch damit nur Schindluder treiben, oder? Du würdest doch einfach entweder, naja, das ist woran wir alle denken, oder halt einfach ... Ich denke immer noch an GTA-Cheatcodes. Ich auch.
Ich glaube, das ist zu viel Macht einfach, oder?
Man spielt ein bisschen vor.
Ja, weil dann irgendwie, wenn du dann merkst,
so irgendwie dein Freund Rudi und du hast Rudi
und Rudi sagt, ja, ich habe mir jetzt diese neue App runtergeladen,
das Podcast-Ufo, da kann man Frauen kennenlernen,
denkst dir, weißt du was, fick dich Rudi so,
du lernst niemanden kennen,
du matchst niemanden, egal wie gut du bist, egal was für coole spontane Unterwasserfotos du hast,
fünfmal am Tag, fünf in deiner Woche, nichts, das wäre zu viel Macht.
Du bist so eine Marionette, so ein Marionettenspieler bist du dann,
das ist nicht mehr eine natürliche Selektion, sondern Florentinselektion.
Genau, das ist die nächste Evolutionsstufe, wenn ich einfach entscheide, dass Rudi niemanden abkriegt.
Ich glaube, es fällt relativ schnell auf, wenn niemand Matches hat außer dir.
Nicht so anders wie auf Tinder, sag ich mal.
Der Entwickler steht ganz oben.
Ich bin Helena Treu, macht euch keine Sorgen.
Ihr seid nicht zusammen, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das nochmal...
Ja, woher weiss ich das denn? Vielleicht eines Tages...
Ja, weil ihr euch seit 17 Jahren nicht mehr gesehen habt. Na. Dann habe ich halt meinen Freunden auch so erzählt, so, ja, ne, also ich habe meine Freundin so, Helena, ich weiss nicht, wo sie wohnt, ich weiss nicht mehr genau, wie sie aussieht. Sie hat Schiggy ausgespielt, so weiss ich noch, und die haben auch schon gesagt, vor allem die haben es mir nicht mal nicht geglaubt, weil es so erbärmlich war. Die haben gesagt, ja, kann sein. Nee, ich glaube, die wollten nicht mehr, dass du die Fresse heisst und den nächsten Zug machst. Jetzt hör auf, von deinem Ressort zu erzählen und mach den nächsten Zug. Ich weiss leider nicht, wie Pokémon-Kartenspiel funktioniert. Ach, ich weiss noch, wie da am Pool saßen und sie die Wasserenergie ausgespielt hat.
Ja, ich habe ja wie gesagt hier Glumanda ausgespielt.
Ja, ich greife wieder mit Shigi an und mach dir 60 Schaden, du hast keine Chance, du hast verloren.
Wie spielt man Pokémon?
Okay, dann bin ich dran. Okay, oh, okay, all in. Das ist schwierig. Da wird ein Pokerchip wieder gut, oder? Schach ist wie Pokémon-Karten spielen, nur ohne all in. Ja, das ist schwierig. Auf der anderen Seite irgendwann, ich glaube, wir müssen noch mal ran an die Emojis. Eines Tages können wir noch mal ein Emoji pitchen. Weil es gibt ja, wenn ich richtig gut fand, war der geschmolzene Emoji, der mit dem geschmolzenen Lächeln. Den gefrorenen gibt es auch schon. Die Elemente sind fast durch, außer Stein, wie immer, das unbeliebteste der Elemente. Deswegen, wie wäre es mit einem Stein? Wer hier würde den... Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, es gibt ja Stein, oder? Es gibt Rock. Ja, aber nicht mit einem Gesicht. So ein Stein mit einem Gesicht, so im Sinne von, ah, ein gefrorenes Lächeln. Sorry, Sie durften nur hierher kommen zum Pitchen, weil Sie eben gute Verbindungen haben und so. Sie verstehen. Okay, wir wurden gerade ge... Was?
Sind wir... Bitte, was ist gerade passiert?
Ich bin zu langsam für spontaner Moment.
Ja, wirklich? Das heißt... Oh, seine Be-Real-App hat gerade angefragt und er musste jetzt gerade ein Foto machen. Mega gut. Dann müsst ihr jetzt ein Foto machen. Oh, noch 55 Sekunden. Okay, dann lass uns ein Foto von ... Man kann Videos machen, richtig? Kann man Videos machen? Okay, lass uns ein Foto machen. Können wir ein bisschen Licht im Publikum haben, bitte? Dann machen wir ein Foto von uns allen. Ich habe mich noch nie so alt gefühlt. Ja, ich schon. Hey, what is happening? Sehr schön. Wow, mit Blitz, das ist bestimmt geil geworden. Nicht schlecht. Schau mal. Das ist real. Wow. Mega. Er hat so doll gelacht, er hätte nicht gedacht, dass das Bild was geworden ist. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass wir so junge Leute im Publikum haben. Nicht schlecht. Be real Benachrichtung ist raus. Schon so geflügeltes Wort. Be real Benachrichtung ist raus. Und wir beide, what? Wir haben darüber gerade gesprochen. Was ist wieder Krie gesprochen, wir sind so uncool, dass wir über die App sprechen, die neu ist, jemand ruft ins Publikum, die Be Real Benachrichtigung ist raus und wir brauchen eine Minute, um zu verstehen, was gerade passiert ist. Ich finde dich cool. Ich finde dich auch richtig cool. Dankeschön, das ist das Wichtigste für mich. Scheisse, sonst, ja. Aber sonst ist alles scheisse. Das ist schwierig. Wie geht es deinem Rücken, Stefan? Geht es besser beim Rücken? Ja, es geht jetzt ein bisschen besser. Ja, ich mache Übungen. Kuh, Katze? Ich mache auch Übungen. Machst du auch Kuh, Katze? Ich bin schon weiter, ich bin schon bei Katze, Kuh, so wo du dann wieder, wo du es wieder umdrehst. Aber ganz kurz. Na, ganz kurz. Aber Kühe stehen da nicht so mit durchgehängendem Rücken, oder? Nee, ich glaube nicht. Ich habe Kühe eh noch nicht gecheckt, also gar nicht. Manche Tiere kann man biegen und manche nicht. Aber es gibt irgendwie keine Regel. So ein Hund, vergiss es, es ist wie ein Tisch, da kannst du einfach so ein Glas draufstellen. Katze, vergiss es. Katze ist wie so eine Hängematte, so eine lebende Hängematte. Und bei anderen Tieren, wenn mir jetzt jemand so ein Waschbär vorsetzen würde, biegt oder nicht, das ist die perfekte neue RTL-Show, biegt's oder nicht. Und du hast einfach so ein Tier und du denkst dir, ja stimmt, ein Fuchs, ist ein Fuchs näher an der Katze oder am Hund? Was ist das eigentlich? Ja genau, das wollen wir ja schon seit Ewigkeiten herausfinden. Aber du glaubst, was würde mit einer Kuh passieren? Ja, dann kommt Sonja Zitlow und macht ihm so einen Gürtel an und dann wird an dem Gürtel so hochgezogen und manche Tiere sind dann wie so ein Tisch, so straight hoch wie ein Hund und manche Tiere so einfach so wie eine Katze, einfach so ohne Rückenstärke, einfach so nichts. Aber die Frage ist ja, was würdest du machen, wenn man dich jetzt mit deinem neuen Rücken üben. Gute Frage, gute Frage, aktuell ich habe dir vielleicht den stärksten Rücken meines Lebens. Okay, ich hatte noch nie so einen starken Rücken. Das heißt, wenn ich dich jetzt hochheben würde in der Mitte, würdest du dich nicht bebiegen. Steinhardt, steinhardt wie ein Tisch. Aber ich finde dich aber echt spannend, Schlange zum Beispiel, Schlange, wenn man die Schlange so hoch nimmt, ist die komplett schlaff oder hat die zumindest so in ihrer Horizontalen eine gewisse Festigkeit. Ich weiß nicht, ich fände es eine geile Show und die Show heisst Das Podcast Suchen. Auf RTL. Okay, jetzt ist wieder lustig der Gag, ich verstehe es nicht. Und wir ziehen es hoch. Jetzt lachen die wieder. Ich weiss nicht mehr weiter. Vielleicht nix an dir, Stefan. Oder eine Eidechse oder so, wer weiss, wie die biegt. Wo hat die ihr Angelegen? Eine Eidechse wär super weird, die würde den Schwanz abwerfen und wär cool. Ja, tatsächlich, ich hab tatsächlich, äh, weiss man, ich mach... Bei deinen Schweanz abgeworfen. Zotige Gagzeug. Ich habe tatsächlich eine überfahrene Eidechse gesehen und die wurde halt, also die hat es hart erwischt, einfach straight über den Kopf, einfach so, als wäre ein Attentat gewesen. Und sie hat ihren Schwanz abgeworfen, wo ich mir dachte, ich habe mir die jetzt angeguckt und dachte mir, ja, netter Versuch.
Sie hat wirklich getan, was sie konnte. Ja, aber angenommen, du bist ein Mensch, wir können als letzte Tat so als Ablenkung unseren Arm abwerfen. Du läufst die Strasse entlang, siehst über dir das Klavier, siehst schon so comikhaft, das Seil ist durch, es hat nur noch so ein Zipfelchen. Ja. Du läufst runter und denkst, scheisse, wie ist es runterkommen?
Natürlich wirfst du den Arm ab, weil es dein letzter Ausweg ist. Vielleicht schiebt dich das ja ein bisschen nach hinten. Kann sein, ja, stimmt. Oder meinst du, es hätte sie abgelenkt und die Eidexte hat lieber noch mal mehr Gedankenkraft in diesen letzten Hieb zur Seite investiert. Oder sie hat sich extra in das Auto geschossen, kann auch sein, deutlich, ich weiss nicht, wie die funktionieren. Selbstmord. Aber das war ein bisschen erbärmlich, wo ich mir dachte, der Mensch ist schon ein Stück krasser als die Natur. Der Mensch hat ein zwei Tonnen schweres Gerät aus Stahl, wo er einfach irgendwie mit Erdsoße einfach die Gegend fahren kann und die Eidechse hat ... ja, ich kann meinen Schwanz abwerfen, wenn es sein muss. Klar, es war mir noch nie so deutlich, dass wir auf der richtigen Seite stehen. Ja, das ist einfach besser. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das erzählt habe, aber diese Ich-Waier-in-Peru.
Wirklich? Wollen wir die Dias noch mal anschauen? Ja, hol den Kasten. Ich habe ein paar Fotos mitgebracht. Buenos Dias mit Stefan Tietzel.
Buenos Dias, das ist ein Sombrero.
Was hast du da erlebt?
Genau, da war ich ja bei den berühmten Nazca-Linien, aber jetzt pass auf, pass auf, hey! Hey, ich verspreche dir, das wird nicht boring und langweilig, wie die acht Stunden, die du dir die Dias angucken musst bei mir zu Hause, wo es keine Snacks gab, wo ich kein, ich hab nichts zu trinken damit, ich weiß, die meisten saßen auf dem Boden, du musstest dir achten, meine...
Oh, ich bin stabil, ich bin stabil.
Stabil.
Achtung.
Das machen wir im Nachhinein, können wir da mit CGI noch viel.
Ich dachte, ich könnte das, ich dachte, ich könnte einfach von meinem Rücken so cool auf die Beine springen.
Das wäre mal... Ich dachte einfach, ich kann das, ich dachte, jeder kann das. rücken so cool auf die beine springen das wäre einfach ich kann das das wäre mal ein be real moment genau mitten im flug so geht die kamera so lächerlicher versuch wow was hast du erzählt was erlebt in peru und das lustige war dass die nazca jetzt hör mal auf dass du dich dafür gar nicht interessierst. Ich verstehe nicht mal, was du sagst. Du sprichst nicht mal in dein Mikrofon. Sorry, Entschuldigung, sorry, okay, dann erzähl, erzähl. Pass auf, jetzt ist es ja nicht mehr so cool. Ich versuche es trotzdem noch mal zu erzählen. Die Nazca haben 600 vor Christus eine riesengroße Eidechse in die Wüste, die Atacama-Wüste gemalt. Oh ja, die ist riesig gross. Leider hat man diese riesen Kunstwerke erst super spät entdeckt mit der kommerziellen Luftfahrt und hat deswegen den Highway genau durch das Bild der Eidechse gebaut. Das ist kein Scherz. Und es ist eins von drei Bildern von 5000 oder sowas, die man sich angucken kann von diesem kleinen Aussichtshurm, wo ich war.
Das heißt, ich bin hochgestiefelt, grösster Fan, Maskerlinien-T-Shirt angehabt und so, so meinen Entdeckerhut aufgesetzt. Und was man sieht, ist eine riesengroße Eidechse, wo in der Mitte der Highway durchgeht. Als ob die Ureinwohner sagen würden, Eidechsen, nein, danke. Ja, genau. Aber das ist so sinnbildlich, weil kein Tier wird, glaube ich, so oft überfahren wie diese länglichen Eidechsen, die wir auch, glaube ich, nicht einschätzen können, wie lang sie sind. Ja, es ist perfekt. Wir haben quasi die Zukunft direkt vorhergesagt, einfach Autos direkt drüber. Es ist super sinnbildlich, genau in der Mitte. Aber was sind die anderen Motive? Also wir haben Eidechse. Das will ich jetzt gar nicht mehr erzählen. Ich finde es ja selber boring. Nein, aber ich würde schon interessieren, welche Motive man sich überlegt. Ja, würde es sich interessieren? Ja? Ja. Okay, also es gibt verschiedene, ich spreche sofort ein, nee es gibt tatsächlich, ich weiß es auch nicht, es gibt noch Flamingo, es gibt noch Baum, boring Baum, es gibt einen Wal, einen Wal? Ja, es gibt einen Wal. Menschen, Affen, es gibt einen Affen, einen langen Ringelschwanz. Ich finde das. Das Publikum ist begeistert. Die werden heute Abend nach Hause gehen und sagen, Schatz, und dann hat er alle Naskalinen aufgezählt. Und ich glaube, da war ein Affe und ich weiß gar nicht mehr. Und dann hat er gesagt, Wahle, ich dachte, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Wie geht das denn? Und dann sagt er, Baum, boring, so auch nicht boring, super. Aber also, Wale finde ich spannend, weil ich meine, wie viele Wale haben denn die Menschen damals in ihrem Leben gesehen? Ja, das habe ich auch gefragt. Wenn du Glück hast, siehst du einen in deinem gesamten Leben, wenn du am Meer lebst. Und dann sagst du, Leute, wir haben riesigen Fisch gesehen. Wie sah der aus? Ja, ich mal's dir auf ein riesen Bild in die Wüste, was du erst sehen kannst, wenn du 80 Kilometer in die Luft steigst.
Ich glaube, weil die haben ja sehr lange gelebt, wie 600 vor Christus bis sagen wir mal 1000 nach Christus.
Ja, okay.
Und da hatten die ja genug Zeit, aufs Meer zu gucken, ne?
Ja.
Und diese Linien in die Wüste zu zeichnen.
Bin kein Fan mehr.
Was, gibt es Fragen aus Publikum?
Ich denke mir immer, das ist ein genervter Professor.
Nein, einfach so der erste Mensch, der auf seinem kleinen Fischboot ist und plötzlich so... Und er kennt nur diese Fische, er kennt diese kleinen Fische, die angelt.
Er kommt her, er kommt her, damals noch mit der Hand einfach aus dem Wasser, da waren die Meere noch nicht überfischt. Kleine Gesellschaftskrise. Ne, muss auch sein, andere haben der nebenbei, nicht tief. Fischte da und dann plötzlich so, wird es kommen, so ein dunkler Schatten plötzlich, so ein riesiger Wal einfach, spritzt auch noch Wasser während man in Deine Luft ist raus. Was einen Regenbogen entstehen lässt. Du denkst, what the fuck! Einfach der riesige Wal neben dir. Und dann läuft er ins Dorf zurück. Ja, und er denkt sich so, das kann ich niemandem erzählen. Niemand wird mir das glauben. Im Dorf spielen die coole Würfelspiele. Hey Leute, hey Leute, ohne Scheiss, ich war gerade draußen. Ja, warte, warte kurz, ich habe fünf Fünnen, ich habe neunzehn Sechsen. Das kann ich nicht überbieten, glaubt. Das ist ein ziemlich einseitiges Brett, aber trotzdem, lass mich bitte erzählen. Ich war gerade fischen und ich habe ein riesengroßes Fischwesen gesehen, es ist nicht mehr aus dem Wasser gesprungen, es ist riesengroß und es hat auch noch Wasser geschossen aus seiner Nase oder was? Mega krass. Ne, wirklich, das ist, ich hab, warte, ich mal's euch auf. Mal's kurz auf. Gib mir 140 Jahre. Ja. Und dann so. Warte, warte. Man weiss nicht, wie sie das gemacht haben damals. Stell dir vor, du bist ein riesengrosser Künstler. Alle feiern deine Kunstwerke, aber deine Technik ist... Ja, eine riesen... Warte, das erkennt man am Ende. Das ist wie bei Jackson Pollock, so Kunstwerke sehen mir geil aus, aber seine Technik war... Ja, aber folgendes. Ich liebe ja diese... Liebst du Jackson Pollock? Nee, Kunst im Alter. Ich liebe das. Also ich finde das klasse, mit den Farben und ich finde das super. Okay. Also das ist so krass. Die Farben findest du super? Die Farben finde ich krass. Weil klar, heute denkt man sich gut, Laserdrucker, Laser hat eh alle Farben, aber dann siehst du da vor so einem Bild und denkst dir, ja, 1408, und denkst dir, wo hat der denn die Farbe hier? Wie funktioniert ein Laserdrucker? Wie ein Laserdrucker funktioniert, sorry. Ach, weisst du nicht? Nee. Weisst du nicht? Achso, okay, kann ich ja ... Also, du hast ja gerade eben schon selber gesagt, Regenbogen. In der Story davor. Genau, Regenbogen. Regenbogen kommt ja daher, weil in dem Licht, das wir so kennen, sind alle Farben drin. Ziemlich krass, ne? Na ja, sind alle Farben drin? Genau. Und Laser ist ja Licht quasi so gedrückt, so wie so, wenn du, stell dir so einen nassen Schwamm vor, den du so, aber Moment, Moment mal kurz, weil es ist ja, Licht sind ja Wellenlinien, wie kann das gedrückt sein, da gibt es ja eine andere Farbe. Genau, ja. Und jetzt nennen Sie dir die Wellen. Sir, Sir, Sir, okay. Sie antworten nicht auf meine Fragen, sie sagen immer nur okay oder genau, aber ich stelle dir eine Frage, weil ich weiß, dass es klausurrelevant ist.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Fragen dann, ja, dann stell dir eine Frage. Sie haben gerade gesagt, das ist gedrückt, die Wellen, aber es gibt ja eine andere Farbe, weil die Wellen.
Alle zusammen, stell dir so eine Mundharmonika vor. Ja, okay, ich weiß nicht, was das mit dem konkreten Ring so... Und dann einfach mal... Also Licht macht keinen Ton. Licht macht keinen Ton. Schreibt euch das auf, schreibt euch das auf. Wenn ihr irgendwas hört, wisst ihr, kein Licht. Könnt ihr schon mal direkt ausschliessen? Ja, ich... Nee, nee. Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah. Komm in die Tüte. Nee, mhm. Und dann wird es halt zusammengedrückt und dann, weil wir haben ja gesehen, im Regenbogen, im Licht sind alle Farben drin und im Laser sind dann ja auch alle Farben drin und der Drucker sagt dann Blau, Rot, Magenta, Magenta. Zyran, Magenta, ja. Aber Sie versuchen es irgendwie anschaulich. Terracotta. Okay. Chicago. Was ist Chicago? Das ist eine neue Farbe. Lachs? Lachs, ja das ist wie so ein Blau. Niemand versteht Farbennamen, das ist schwierig. Der Drucker sagt Blau. Genau. Und dann sagt das Licht, jo, machen wir! Und ran ans Papier und dann so. Sagst du noch Fragen oder? Nee, ich möchte Ihnen nie wieder eine Frage stellen. Haben wir doch was gelernt. Weiß ich nicht, ob wir was gelernt haben. Heute ist es kein Problem, aber wenn du da vor so einem Künstler, 1400 Jan-Jansengendwas, Jan Jansen, so 1408, und dann denkst du dir, wo kommen die ganzen Farben her? So für eine, bei einer Farbe, so bei Rot weiß ich's, da haben die schon Schnecken gedrückt. Ja, auch das habe ich in Peru gesehen, tatsächlich, das ist kein Scherz. Ich wünschte auch, dass ich jetzt ein anderes Land nennen kann, oder, oh, das habe ich mal in einer Doku gesehen, aber warum soll ich euch denn anlügen? Stefan, du musst entweder... Man kann auf Parasiten drücken, auf Kakteen, ganz kurz, bevor du wieder gelangweilt sein kannst. Nee, eins will ich sagen, du musst entweder mehr reisen oder weniger. Okay. Du bist genau in dem Bereich, wo es nervig ist. Es ist die zweite Folge. Weil du hast genug gesehen, damit du damit Nerven kannst, aber zu wenig, dass eine Varianz tritt.
Ja, es ist doch nicht beeindruckend. Es ist nicht nur krass, was weiß er alles, sondern ich habe eine Anekdote im Seltsen.
Aber jetzt lass mich raten, welche Farbe kommt aus Kakteen? Da bin ich jetzt wirklich gespannt.
Nee, nee, nee.
Welche Farbe kommt aus Kakteen?
Sag's uns, bitte.
Grün, aber die Parasiten auf den Kakteen.
Ah, das ist eine geile Story.
Nein, pass auf, die Parasiten auf den Kakteen, die drückt man platt und das ist das beste Rot der Welt. Und deswegen wurde daraus rot gemacht. Die Parasiten auf den Kakteen? Genau, richtig. Das sind so kleine, wie so Milben. Die drückst da drauf und das ist perfektes Rot. Und das gleich meinst du auch. Ich dachte Schnecken. Aber weil du hast ja clever nur gesagt Parasiten, du hast ja technisch nicht gesagt, welches Tier, das heißt, es kann ja jetzt alles sein.
Man muss bei Stefan manchmal aufpassen, weil der formuliert Dinge absichtlich so, dass er ganz viel offen ist.
Ja, mit meinem Anwalt formuliert.
Er wird nochmal drüber geguckt überall.
Da wird selbst über sowas drüber geguckt.
Aber finde ich geil, weil es schränkt dich ja schon ein als Künstler, wenn du halt zwei Farben hast, rot und blau und dann mal da mal ein Bild damit, wie so ein 3D-Brillenbild. Was war dann genau in Picassos blauer Phase los eigentlich? Verrückt, ne? Das fragt man sich dann, was war da los, blau, was ist das eigentlich blau? Nee, frag ich Sie. Ja, ja. Ich sage immer, Kunst gibt uns Fragen und keine Antworten.
Ich hasse meine Kunstgeschichte, Professor.
So sehr.
Weil manchmal ist die Frage viel hilfreicher als die Antwort.
Weisst du, die Farbe ist ja auch der Grund, warum hier Wolfgang Beltracki, der berühmte Kölner Kunstfälscher,
der Millionen, über Millionen umgesetzt hat, weil er Bilder nachgemalt hat, auch Picassos und so, der wurde nur geschnappt, weil auf einem Bild plötzlich ein berühmter Kampendonk von ihm wurde das falsche Weiss entdeckt. Ein Weiss, was erst in den letzten Jahren irgendwie, das Titanweiss, wo ich dachte, wirklich in Weiss?
Weil er hat die sogar gebrannt, hat die in den Ofen gesteckt und so, hat sich alte Rahmen gekauft, wo er dann genau wusste, es ist von 1940 aus Barcelona ein Rahmen und so, hat auf alles geachtet,
aber er ist zu Hornbach gegangen, hat sich in Weiss gekauft.
Bei jeder Farbe denkt man sich, ah, du kriegst mich, aber nicht bei Weiss.
Aber sorry, wozu braucht man weisse Farbe? Die Leinwand ist doch weiss. Ja, aber jetzt pass auf. Also du brauchst, lass das einfach frei. Jetzt pass auf. Pass auf. Oder sorry, Entschuldigung, Kunstgeschichte. So mache ich das, wenn ich ein Bild mal und es muss was weiss sein, lasse ich es frei. Herr Beltracki, hört da jemand zu? Picasso! Hallo, mitgedacht. Das ist ja wirklich Quatsch. Aber glaubst du, dass man jede Farbe kaufen kann? Glaubst du, dass man jede Farbe ist? Ist jede Farbe käuflich? Oder meinst du, es gibt Farben, die sagen, nee, mich wirst du niemals besitzen wie Helena? Okay, mir geht's gut. Ja, weil du solltest richtig langsam darüber hinwegkommen, weil es ist schon so lange her, Mann. Ja, ich weiß, meine Liebe wird stärker jeden Tag. Wirklich? Das klingt furchtbar. Ja, es ist wirklich schrecklich. Das ist 17 Jahre her. Das ist wirklich schrecklich. Das ist richtig schrecklich. Sie wird jeden Tag stärker? Es gibt Wochen, da flaut es wieder ein bisschen ab, aber würde man sich den Trend insgesamt angucken, steigt es ja. Steigt es langsam an. Ja. Aber wie willst du Chicago mischen? Aus welchen Farben? Nochmal? Chicago? Ja, deine Farbe. Deine Farbe, ich meine. Wie willst du die mischen? Brauchst du da vielleicht eine Farbe für, die das aufhält? Gelb. Meine Farbe Chicago wäre so eine Farbe, die anders ist, wenn man sie aus zwei Winkeln betrachtet. So wie so Bilder, die von der einen Seite ein Hase sind, von der anderen Seite ein leicht anderer Hase. Das habe ich gesagt. Was geht denn hier? Von der einen Seite ein Hase, von der anderen Seite ein Kaninchen. Nicht zu wechseln mit meinem Bild, was von der einen Seite ein Alligator ist und von der anderen Seite ein Krokodil. Alter. Das ist doch eine andere Spezies. Und sowas fände ich geil, oder halt, weil es gibt ja so Farbe, die im Dunkeln leuchtet, meine Farbe dunkelt im Hell. Versteht ihr? Andersrum. Das heisst, immer wenn es hell ist, ist die fast nicht zu sehen, wenn es dunkel ist, dann hat die Bock, dann wacht die auf. So was, wie Chicago. Chicago ist die Stadt, die niemals schläft, deswegen Nacht und so. Verstehst du? Du musst sehr mitdenken. Es klingt so, wie du redest deine Sprache, wenn du die sagst, jetzt kommt alles zusammen. Willst du es kaufen oder nicht jetzt? Das ist jetzt keine weiteren Fragen. Ne, Moment, du hast es aber falsch erklärt. Wenn es tagsüber, muss es ja sichtbar sein. Sind nicht alle Farben im Gegenteil von im Leuchten dunkelndunkelnden Farben? So, ich muss kurz im Leuchten nicht. Leider, ganz dumm gelegten Tenden leider jetzt noch gerade, ich habe eine Wohnungsbesichtigung. Und be real auch noch. Und be real in der Wohnung mit dem Makler so, Leute. Aber ist eine be real Mitteilung irgendwann eine gute Ausrede, um so aus so socially awkward Konversationation rauszukommen? Ja, oder? Sorry, ich habe kurz eine Be-Real-Mitteilung. Stimmt, ist richtig gut, jetzt merke ich es erst. Und dann kommst du nie wieder. Aber die Leute fragen dann, warum machst du nicht ein Foto mit mir? Ja, das habe ich auch gedacht. Oder ist es cool, um mit Leuten heimlich Fotos zu machen? So, ah, jetzt mein Be-Real, ich muss mit dem Makler ein Foto machen? Ja. Und dann hast du ein Foto von dem. Ein guter Spion, denkt immer voraus, nicht hinterher, sondern nicht, oh shit, von dem bräuchte ich jetzt ein Foto, nee, vorher, nein, musst du das schon machen. Ich hol mir die App heute Abend noch, weil ich will mein Leben mehr dokumentieren, weil das einzige, was ich habe, um zurückzuschauen, wenn ich mal alt bin und mit Helenaena zusammen auf meinem balkon sitze und zurückschau alles was ich habe sind 300 podcast folgen aber es wie tagebogen in denen ich nostalgisch blättern kann ja und moin moin das stimmt ja das stimmt ja guter punkt nee dann vergiss es habe ich gut einfach das stimmt danke dass Lad die runter, lad die runter, zur Sicherheit. Lad sie runter, alle. Aber ich stelle mir vor, wenn wir irgendwann ... Das ist ja unser Art Tagebuch, ne? Sehr ausführliches Tagebuch, einmal die Woche. Und wenn wir mal irgendwann zurückblicken und uns schon lange verstritten haben, hast du halt ein Tagebuch, wo halt die Hälfte halt so ein anderer Dude spricht.
Den ich auch vergessen habe. Wie ging es mir da? Wie ging es mir im September 2022? Und dann redet Florian über Farben.
Ja, weil ich meine, in der Zukunft wird es ja wahrscheinlich Technologie geben, mit denen man Erinnerungen löschen kann.
Und dann kannst du ja sagen...
Klar, da sind wir uns alle einig.
Ja, dann kannst du sagen, ja, weil jetzt zum Beispiel so Liebeskummer oder so, Beziehung geht zu Ende und dann sagst du, ey, eigentlich kein Problem. Ich meine, ich meine, ich meine, ich meine, ich meine, ich meine, ich meine, ich meine, ich meine, ich meine, ich, komisch ist in unserem Jahrzehnt immer noch das Telefon, die diese nervigen Geräusche macht. Es ist eine App. Es ist eine App für das Leben. Wir wollten die löschen, Schatz. Wer bist du? Deine Frau, deine Hologrammfrau. Ich habe dich wahrscheinlich gerade gelöscht. Ach so, zack. Aber dann kann es alles löschen. Würdest du die löschen, würdest du Helena aus deinem Gedächtnis löschen? Boah, das ist Stefan, ey, für so eine lockere Abendunterhaltung haust du jetzt solche Fragen aus, würdest du die Erinnerung an deine verflossene Liebschaft löschen, wenn du es könntest? Ey Leute, hört gestern ist der Geisterband, wenn ihr solche Fragen beantwortet haben möchtet. Die sind ja bekannt. Nicht wir, nicht wir. Hört Sternstunde Philosophie oder gestern ist der Geisterband dafür. Nee, aber das ist nur eine Frage an dich, weil du bist ja nicht unzufrieden mit deinem Leben. Du bist gerade hier, du sprichst vor sehr vielen Leuten, du hast Großartiges erreicht in deinem Leben, du magst dich, du bist mit dir im Rhein, aber Helena ist Teil dessen, Teil dieses Lebens, was du magst. Okay. Sie ist Teil deiner Vergangenheit, Teil deines Fogesieds. Also du sagst, nur weil ich sie so lange in Erinnerung getragen habe, konnte ich das tun, was ich getan habe, neue Farben erfinden, neue Habs erfinden. Ohne den Koma mit dir hätte ich das nicht. Du meinst, die negativen Dinge gehören genauso zum Leben wie die positiven? Genau. Wow. Wie schlecht. Stefan Tietze, meine Damen und Herren, wir haben alle was gelernt. Aber unsympathisch. Stell dir mal vor, er ist ein Psychologe. Ich fand dein Zufrieden, dein Zufrieden ist Nicken eher noch unsympathisch. Stell dir mal vor, so ein Psychologe. Ich fand dein Zufrieden ist Nicken eher noch unsympathischer. Ja, das habe ich jetzt verdient. Stell dir mal vor, du hast irgendwie so eine Therapiesession oder sowas und irgendwann hast du so mega durchbruchend und sagst so mega danke, vielen Dank, dass wir so geholfen haben und er steht auf und geht einfach raus. Mic drop, ciao Leute, macht's gut, ich bin. Geheilt. Es ist in jedem anderen Beruf mega weird. Ja, schön schön. Auch wenn du so sagst, wo stehen die Milky Ways? In Reihe C, bitte. Ah ja, alles klar, danke schön. Danke schön, vielen Dank. Mic drop, das war's. Das war's. Freunde, genailed. Wo stehen die Milky Ways? Wo stehen die Milky Ways? Sie sind vor allem so verbeugen, wie so Wiener Staatsoper. Ja. Schauspiel. Wo steht die Milky Ways? Vor allem würden sie sich so verbeugen, wie so Wiener Staatsoper, Schauspieler. Wo stehen die Milky Ways? Das ist auch einfach die erbärmlichste Frage, die es geben kann. Jesus Christ. Wie lange hast du gesucht? Wie lange hast du gesucht, bis du sagst, fuck ey, ich find die nicht? Entschuldigung, wo sind die Milky W's, die Milky Way's, wo sind die Milky Way's, ja. Kommt mal alle zusammen. Ihr wisst nicht, was er gerade gefragt hat, wo die fucking Milky Way's sind. Sag mir einfach, wo die sind, ey. Ja, wo denn, beim Duplo. Ah, fuck, ja klar. Neben dem Mars. Das wäre auch gemeinin. Wenn ich eine Supermacht sage, Supermarkt haben würde. Supermacht. Supermacht, kleiner freudscher Versprecher. Ja. Eigentlich will ich gar keinen Supermarkt, sondern ich will die Supermacht. Und jetzt ist es raus. Und in fünf Jahren, wenn ich Diktator bin, können die dir sagen, da wollte er schon die Supermacht haben. Das ist aber weird, dass der Typ, der die Wel Weltherrschaft an sich reisen will, einen Podcast macht. Ja, na ja, Künstler gibt's schon, aber auf der anderen Seite, ich glaube, ich würde eine Sache so ganz woanders hin tun im Supermarkt, wo es niemand vermuten würde. Einfach damit die Leute denken, ah, okay, Mehl, Mehl, Mehl. Nee, damit die nicht aufhören zu suchen. Ja. Damit die nicht immer denken, ah, sie wähnen sich in den richtigen, dass die alle schon kennen, weißt du, weil wenn irgendwas Schlimmes passiert, Zombie-Apokalypse, laufen Leute immer noch durch den Gang und sagen, hier werden jetzt die Avocados, da die Brokkolis, nein, man muss doch den Leuten, man darf auch Tauben nicht die ganze Zeit füttern, weil die sonst vergessen zu essen, das heißt, wir müssen mal irgendwann alle Supermärkte ummodellieren. Ja, obwohl, es passiert ja ab und zu. Ab und zu ist ja ein Supermarkt komplett neu eingerichtet. Aber nicht komplett neu. Also wirklich so, dass die Regale sich verändern. Nee, nee, nee. Du hast nicht hinten das Obst. Man hat nie hinten das Obst. Nee, man hat nie hinten das Obst. So ist die Folge. Man hat nie hinten das Obst. Aber es ist schon woanders. Und mir ist es tatsächlich schon passiert. Ich stand vor einem Regal, Süsswaren, dachte, ruck mich um und dachte mir, was will ich denn mit so Dosen-Saft haben und so. Und stellte sich heraus, haben die komplett umgestellt. Ich habe es nicht gecheckt, bin einfach wie so ein trainierter Dackel, einfach da sabbernd der Glocke hinterher, einfach so, wo ist das Mickey, ey, bis ich gemerkt habe, die haben mich in die Ecke gelockt. Ich glaube, die machen das absichtlich, damit Leute unbewusst neue Sachen kaufen. Damit du Gedanken verloren, die vier sich aus der Dose kaufen. Damit ich Gedanken verloren, mir vier Dosen, habe ich heute noch vier Dosen Pfirsiche. Und dann ist der Abend so, machst dann auch einen Dosenöffner, machst die Dose auf, nimmst es und denkst, Moment mal, das ist gar kein Milky-Way-Riefe! Das ist ja gesund! Ah, Edeka! Ah, es brennt, es brennt! Netto! Andere Einzelhandelskaufmarken. Aber eigentlich alle. Jeder hat doch eine so eine Dose zu Hause, die da lauert. Für den Dachschwein. Die das vor seit fucking Jahren ist. Und die ist da und sie weiss, dass du weisst, dass sie da ist und du weisst auch, dass du sie wahrscheinlich nie anröhnen wirst. Aber du bringst nicht übers Herz, sie wegzuschmeißen. Was bei dir? Bei mir ist es tatsächlich Pfefferminzmarmelade. Wir waren zusammen vor vier, fünf Jahren in New York und ich dachte mir, Pfefferminzen-Marmelade, Holy Crap, habe ich noch nie gesehen. Was? Nehme ich natürlich mit, durch den Zoll, durchgeschmuggelt, ich habe es in der Hose getragen, im Flugzeug, war in Deutschland, stellt sie mir hin, denkt mir, ja, irgendwie auch nicht so geil. Und das war jetzt vor fünf Jahren und seitdem jeden Morgen auf dem Weg in die Küche, morgen, morgen, ja, morgen, einfach, und wir wissen genau so, diese Beziehung führt zu nichts, es wird nichts mehr. Wie Helena. Das war unsere Show. Wow, dankeschön, da hören wir auf, Leute, dankeschön, macht's gut, vielen Dank, dass Sie da waren. Das war wirklich unsere Show. Dankeschön, letztlich es ist kein Witz, die Show ist nicht tatsächlich zu Ende.
Es ist auch ein Witz, es ist ein Showende und ein Witz in einem.
Aber unbefriedigend, I see that, für uns sehr lustig.
Vielen Dank Leitzig, es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Hat noch einen schönen Abend.
Habt ihr einen, vielen Dank fürs Kommen.
Dankeschön.
Frau Stephan-Maria-Tietze.
Und Florentin-David- oder Pascal David Will! Dankeschön, haben noch einen schönen Abend! Und wir heben ab! Mach's gut! Ciao, ciao, mach's gut! Ciao!